ida roared ashore in louisiana as a
category 4 hurricane carrying winds of
about 150 miles per hour also stoking
fear storm surge could bring massive
flooding and damage to a wide swath of
the gulf we are tracking every angle of
this with our team of reporters tonight
let's start with our cbs news
correspondent michael george who has the
latest from new orleans tonight
well sasha i can tell you we're still
getting pounded by ida it is hovering
overhead right now
the wind was the biggest issue at first
those powerful winds that you mentioned
now it's the rain it is coming down
torrentially here we're seeing reports
of flooding all throughout the area here
right now we're in the french quarter in
new orleans we've seen trees down we've
seen roofs ripped off of the of the top
of the buildings it's just going to be a
very long night for people here
the extremely dangerous hurricane made
landfall in louisiana as one of the
strongest storms in the state's history
as ida continues to pick up strength the
storm's impact is being felt and feared
throughout the gulf conditions are
changing very rapidly and obviously we
have a very dangerous situation on our
hands with hurricane ida fema says the
coasts of louisiana mississippi alabama
and florida are in the life-threatening
storm surge warning area president biden
visited fema headquarters in washington
as the agency prepared emergency
services including food water power
generators and search and rescue teams
this is going to be a devastating a
devastating hurricane
a life-threatening storm new orleans
mayor latoya cantrell warned residents
to stay put in a safe place heed all
warnings ensure that you shelter in
place you hunker down we're in new
orleans famous french quarter just about
50 miles from where hurricane item made
landfall with 150 miles per hour winds
where we are the winds are getting more
and more intense by the hour we're
already hearing reports of downed trees
and roofs being ripped off this tourist
staying at a nearby hotel is worried
about those who are less fortunate we've
got plenty of snacks and water i'm much
more concerned with the homeless
population here in new orleans gulf
state residents were warned to either
evacuate or be aware that emergency
services might not be available during
the height of the storm in its aftermath
utility companies say power outages
could last for weeks
more than 600 000 people have already
lost power at this point and the storm
isn't even close to over yet so this
seems like this is a situation that is
going to take
not just days but possibly weeks to
fully recover from sasha
michael very difficult situation out
there so you mentioned that you know
this is hitting 16 years exactly since
katrina hit in new orleans a really
chilling fact for so many so in terms of
the response and preparedness what
preparedness what has changed since then
yeah a lot of things have changed since
then now the levees and the flood walls
the collapse of those during katrina led
to so many of the loss of life so much
of the damage so much of the flooding
and those have been strengthened
considerably in the past 16 years
billions of dollars spent to reinforce
and strengthen the flood walls and the
levees so the hope is that they will
hold but of course at this part at this
point it's far too early to say it's
going to be a very long night
michael thank you so much for your time
and please stay safe out there